[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le réseau des changes de chaleur et
trois de paris saclay alimente la
majorité des bâtiments du campus urbain
de paris capter et c'est également un
des sites pilotes du projet européen des
touristes ce qui est un projet qui vise
à développer les réseaux de chaleur et
de froid de cinquième génération en
europe dans le cadre du projet des
souris tu le paies à paris saclay met
actuellement en oeuvre un démonstrateur
de gestion avancée de la demande
thermique
l'objectif est d'apporter
flexibilité thermique au réseau en
diminuant les consommations énergétiques
et par là même en diminuant les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
cette première expérimentation vise à
équiper environ 70 logements étudiants
du campus de vin thermostatiques
connecter sans fil ces vins
thermostatiques seront couplées à des
répéteurs qui permettront de communiquer
les données de consommation énergétique
des chambres étudiantes équipe et un
contrôleur qui est contrôleur qui
s'appelle le contrôleur storm et qui a
été développé par fin de nos partenaires
du projet des twins vitaux
ce contrôleur storm permet ainsi d'avoir
un pilotage à distance et permettra
d'avoir une gestion plus fine des
besoins et des consommation en chauffage
par deux moyens le premier c'est que les
usagers vont pouvoir contrôler à
distance la température de consigne de
vote de leur logement via une
application dédiée et dans un second
temps pourra également obtenir à
distance les informations de
consommation sur le consommation sur les
données de consommation
des chambres équipées cela va permettre
d'abaisser les pics de consommation
lorsque cela est nécessaire sans pour
autant diminuer le confort des chambres
équipées pour cette expérimentation nous
sommes accompagnés de plusieurs
partenaires et
diverses associations étudiantes dont
l'association impact et l'association
via un réseau qui se sont notamment
occupé du recrutement des étudiants
volontaires pour participer à
l'expérimentation le cesal qui est le
gestionnaire des résidences étudiantes a
également participé à l'expérimentation
[Musique]